alors tout d'abord nous étions classe
normalement enfin peser notre court
essai nous étions au quatrième étage
quand tout d'un coup ça s'est passé nous
entendions les alarmes la police est
arrivée les médecins arrivent et on ne
débarque et les élèves du côté de la
fenêtre on très bien vu les policiers
arrêté un jeune âge et c'est donc au
début on se demander ce qui s'est passé
on demandait si t'es pas une affaire de
trafic ou un truc du genre mais voilà
nous entendu du bruit dans les couloirs
etc nous savions pas très bien ce qui
s'était passé une fin on était un peu
confus on va dire bien sûr donc à un
moment donné la prochaine sortie enfin
m6 orange aux affaires sortir maintenant
donc là il en train de sortir de la crau
giuly 6 etc on passe on passe dans les
couloirs on commence à sortir en braille
à tous les aînés qui ont été évacués du
justicier parce que il y avait toute la
police autour qui avait entouré entouré
ici pour regarder encore avoir des
cyprès refrain des témoins encore
prévoyez donc on est nous sommes sortis
et le 6 juin il a été âpre et fermé de
sa personne ne pouvait plus rentrer à
abandonner et mais qu'est ce qui s'est
passé en fait pourquoi eux
cl pour y ait eu ce drame alors même les
freins les professeurs ou la police ne
savent pas encore grand chose ils sont
l'élève en question qui est qu à passer
à l'acte il est ensuite fin il est parti
faire un examen psychiatrique et c'est
pourquoi savoir s'ils connaissent et
stella alors je connaissais de vue me
connaissaient pas forcément je voyais
des fois les gens bien on se parle et
parle entre nous cette campagne il avait
un comportement bizarre à l'école alors
bas lors une fois 2e en été dans avec
les psychologues du coup après cette
histoire n'ont voulu en parler exprimer
notre pensée est il des élèves le
connaissaient a été avec lui au collège
donc elle avait dit que quand on était
au collège j'ai été vraiment très
impulsif quand il s'énerve et y casser
les fenêtres au collège etc et cela n'a
pas été signalé au lycée donc voila nous
ont visités il va rajouter mais au
courant de ça en moi j'avais pas quitter
comme ça mais après france info qu'un
peu de de savoir que nous étions en
cours avec un élève qui aurait pu faire
ce genre d'actes et surtout à deux
semaines de la rentrée 1 secondes comme
ça franchement que je comprends pas
comment on peut faire ceci fin avant la
haine contre un prof alors que sa fille
cudos minute comme ça m'est venu aux
messieurs justement on va en parler dans
un son de ce qui était passé gilles
alors ce qui choque énormément et
perturbe même les enquêteurs c'est que
ce jeune agresseur n'a pas d'antécédents
judiciaires il est inconnu des services
de police et qui après il n'y a pas eu
d'altercation avant il s'est précipité
sur l'enseignante une enseignante qui je
crois est est proche de la retraite et
on dit c'est une enseignante expérimenté
très calme il s'est précipité sur elle
avec un couteau il l'a frappé au cou
alors c'était pas effectivement lui qui
étaient en cours avec cette enseignante
l'enseignante a crié à ce moment là j'ai
rien fait et puis elle est tombée alors
ce qui se dit peut-être vous allez nous
le confirmer c'est que il y aurait eu un
conflit entre deux élèves et que peut
être cette enseignante aurait essayé à
sa manière pacifiquement de régler les
conflits et qu'elle aurait pris parti
est ce que vous avez entendu parler de
ça c'est les dernières pistes qui sont
relevés par les enquêteurs alors au
moment de la que nous étions pas dans la
classe oui pendant seulement dans le
même étage mais ce qui s'est passé ce
qu'il ya une élève quitter dans ses
troupes dans cette salle là et du coup
l'élève et il rentre dans la salle il
avait pas cours avec la prof il ne
brille avec personne il avait aucun
problème il est rentré une promesse que
d'après ce qu'on nous a racontée est
entré une première fois et il a essayé
de la poignarder fois il a un peu touché
au niveau du cou et après ici les airs
essayer une deuxième fois sauf que ça
n'a pas très bien marché il a dû courir
et même il sur une photo que tout le
monde sait partager au moment de la
sortie il dit que les gars je vais aller
en prison je sais pas ce qu'il
m'arrivait fin après j'ai pas énerver la
preuve que ça à la fin personne ne
comprenait pas ce qui s'est passé c'est
incroyable j'ai brillé une conversation
sur les réseaux sociaux snap chatte où
il dit j'ai fait une bêtise est-ce que
ça c'est un groupe qui s'est constitué à
ce moment là est ce que vous par exemple
vous avez tout de suite été au courant
de ce de cette conversation sur snapshot
alors ce groupe là je sais pas du tout
quand il a été crié mais comme nous
sommes sortis du lycée tout le monde de
f1 la première personne qui avait cette
photo-là alla directement partager et ça
commence à se partager de plus en plus
car l essca télégramme petit hawks a
donc maintenant tout le monde je suppose
à la photo mais nous étions même pas
mise au courant de ce groupe existe et
où il y avait des personnes alors on va
voir un peu ce que l'auteur des faits
très vite été interpellé par les forces
de l'anp la sortie du lycée comme le
montrent des images amateurs vous et que
vous allez voir et on va revenir sur ce
qui s'est passé après s'est passé avant
c'est vrai que c'est cissé c'est
dramatique vraiment on pense bien sûr à
la professeure et on va jouer et parler
quelqu'un d'être dans un instant
regardez ces images
vraiment 36 mur
donc il a été interpellé immédiatement
il a été placé en garde à vue et c'est
effectivement un examen psychiatrique
parce que personne ne sait ce qui frappe
aussi c'est que vous allez sans doute
nous le confirmer c'est un établissement
scolaire plutôt tranquille fondis cia
2000 élèves il fait bon étudier à dans
ce lycée il n'y a pas eu d'incident
comme ça me le coz réel les profs ne
soit confirmée au cours des années
précédentes il n'y a pas eu c'est sûr ça
surtout ça qu'il est choqué en ce moment
parce que ça arrive d'un coup sans où le
raisin et il n'y a pas eu faim de
moments pour qu'ils aient une haine
contre cette prof là franchement 20 mai
ne comprennent pas du tout on a essayé
de se poser des questions avec mes
camarades eux c'est fait depuis
maintenant et hier que quand on
s'appelle qu'on conserve a dit dégage
été question à se poser est ce qu'ils
nous ont dit les professeurs après les
professeurs qui l'épaule début ils nous
ont rien dit ce tester les élèves une
élève qui tu es c'est avec la preuve du
coup qui va essayer de la maintenir en
vie on va dire et donc justement bravo
hein
cet élève un vraiment voilà je vous le
dis c'est vrai que cette étudiante un
seul studio sapeurs pompiers qui a sauvé
la vie cette enseignante donc bravo
bravo à elle vraiment
et le directeur s'exprimera demain matin
tout à fait je viens de recevoir un
message tout alors qu'il disait que le
directeur et s'exprimant par rapport à
ça par rapport à ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui teinte a envie de retourner
à l'école
franchement si ressort le moment je me
suis pas posé la question j'ai appelé ma
mère je verrai venue du diester fin ça
s'est passé comme ça et enfin je rentre
et je veux pas rester dans un endroit
frais poster pour le moment est donc là
aujourd'hui je ne suis pas allée bien
que
je pense pas retourner de sitôt parce
que franchement c'est une situation chez
quand je compte en veut pas dire oh pas
dire se dire qu'on est dans un endroit
où il peut y avoir un assassin parmi
nous enfin on va dire cdc les celle qui
a osé mais pourrait bien avoir tant
d'autres en fait c'est ça qui fait le
plus peur y
et je me trouvais déjà le bio c'est vrai
que la conversation snapshot et les
troublantes parce que ce jeune homme
juste après avoir poignardé cette
professeur de français et dit je vais en
prison la prof de français j'ai fait une
bêtise et on a l'impression que ses
camarades rigole de ça ils répondent
hall avec des semelles et qui rigole
fils de prendre ses 80 ans là il la
conséquence de la gravité de son geste
ou comme de plus en plus de jeunes
malheureusement il se vante d'avoir
commis des actes ignobles sur les
réseaux sociaux je pense que c'est un
beau jeans avant d'avoir commis cela y
pense que voilà il va être reconnu
maintenant dans les cités alors que il a
clairement foiré sa vie enfin je
comprends pas comment peut-on avoir
entraîné même ses camarades je pense sur
le moment il n'avait pas vraiment cru ce
qu'est ce qu'il disait parce que en même
temps c'est un acte fou de se dire que
fin j'ai planté ma professeure fin je
pense que je vais dire tu la connais
cette professeur alors je n'ai pas en
prof mais bon mais comment tu as des
potes à toi qu ils l'ont eue qui est des
amis à moi qui est en gros pied qu'ils
ont du coup cette prof et voilà
franchement que d'après ce que j'ai
entendu de la prof à la
et maintenant dans pas longtemps allait
partir à la retraite et nos professeurs
de maths l'histoire nous a prévenus que
l la professeure enfin elle va bien
franchement je trouve il avait beaucoup
de potes dont le lycée lui bien c'était
il était instinct d'élèves isolé alors
c'est pas du tout mais c'est et c'est
une des petites connaissances quatre
personnes je crois mais après tout à
l'heure j'ai contacté une personne qui
le connaissent et en sixième est
principalement j'ai parlé avec ses
personnels magic lui qui a été choqué de
ce qu'il est devenu de ce qu'il a fait
c'était enfin ce qui s'est passé à côté
de mon île il avait déjà tu nous disais
qu'il était qu'il a été violent qu'il
était impulsif c'est ce qui ressortait
sais ce que c'est ce que disaient les
autres élèves fiscaliser les professeurs
le service et surtout les élèves qui
étaient avec lui au collège qui savait
très bien ce qu'il faisait et qui tapait
d'écrivains ou était énervé où il
frapper tout ce qui bouge fin voiliers
et après après voilà ça c'est répondu
tout le monde assume on amplifier et
voilà comment vont agiter des camarades
sur le moment c'était la panique ou tout
à fait safin comme nous sommes en tant
qu'homo sommes sortis du lycée
quand je voyais les visages autour des
usages terrifiant
il comprenait pas vraiment ce qui se
passait donc voilà c'est comme ça à
appeler leurs parents commencent à
prévenir lyonnais et 6000 en rigole
trouve pas ça vraiment marrant et y en a
qui a filmé qui ont rigolé belge sur man
2 dans les stories présente dans toutes
les stories externalisant à brive mais
après la plupart je suis bien la plupart
ils s'étaient été choqué c'était triste
pour la profil avec elle va bien et
c'est essentiel aujourd'hui mais
voilà après c'est qu'ils - par exemple
quand je suis sorti j'ai juste et s'est
dirigé nerveux on va dire donc si tu
veux je comprenne et peut enfin c'est
pas vraiment ce qui allait se passer si
le prophète est toujours en vie si les
villes a été capturé au parfum comme
sommes sortis du lycée nous étions
devant devant l'entrée
est-ce qu'il ya un accompagnement
psychologique qui emploie valérie ce
fardeau est ce qu'il ya un
accompagnement psychologique qui vous a
été proposé par le chef d'établissement
il fait mais ils ont mis en place des
salles où il y avait des psychologues où
nous pouvions y aller à plusieurs années
où nous pouvions parler et poser des
questions essayer de discuter de régler
le problème aujourd'hui toi tu apparais
quitté camarades quand vous allez
retourner à l'école demain c'est vrai
que c'est ça sera plus jamais pareil
pour toi
ça se pourrait mais
enfin on va essayer de doubler même si
ça ne s'est pas facile parce que quand
même c'est un acte grave qui est
l'espace et qui est tout près de nous
enfin c'est maintenant c'est la prof ça
peut ça pourrait être envoyée donc les
du coup ça nous choque un peu même les
endroits où les ses laitages là plus
personne qui tu vas trop donc on sera ça
ça va prendre un petit moment à
s'établir mentalement et c'est donc ce
ce jeune homme avait un couteau donc sur
lui
donc il à l'école avec un couteau ce que
vous le saviez qu'il était armé
absolument pas on ne peut pas savoir
windows utilise quel élève et à une arme
sur lui y en a qui se vante d'avoir des
arbustes y en a qui se vante pas de se
dire voilà je vais je fais je vais je
vais faire un truc sur la proche bay
alors amants vraiment il y en a très
rarement mais peut-être y en a un ou
deux meilleurs après c'est très rare de
se dire 25-20 tqc planter les
professeurs surtout cure en éducation
elle est gratuite extérieur officiant au
lieu d'en profiter on est là en fait en
fait du mal à mettre franchement je
trouve ça vraiment dommage il n'avait
pas d'antécédents violence mais vous le
disiez vous même il était agité impulsif
quand il recevait un ordre par rapport à
l'autorité il avait quelques problèmes
pour obéir ça ces élèves là vous même
vous les repérer vous les mettez à
l'écart vous essayé de leur parler ça se
voit que ce sont des élèves non pas
qu'ils vont prendre un couteau mais qui
sont susceptibles d'avoir un
comportement qui peut éventuellement
être dangereux alors si cet élève
j'aurais rencontré au collège auparavant
j'aurais très bien pu penser qu'ils
pourraient amener une arme avec lui moi
mais j'aurais déjà côtoyé pendant pour
le essaie de comprendre pourquoi il fait
ça essayer de l'aider pour aller mieux
au pas mais là franchement il a été
calme cette année il n'a pas du tout
fait des deux problèmes et ça arrive
tout d'un coup je suis d'un jour ont mis
en cause arrive concert comprend pas du
tout pourquoi quelle est la cause est ce
que maintenant vous allez quand vous
retournerez vous allez être plus
vigilant vous dire tient peut-être que
là il faut agir et ce que l on peut
signaler signalé tôt au professeur voilà
lui dire agressif au massif sûrement
enfin avec tout ce qui se passe est
sûrement si je vois quelqu'un de ma
classe freiner les lamas classe où une
élève qui est très agressive avec les
autres ou enfin g ministre a directement
le rôle principal pour lui en parler
qu'est ce que vous dites sur ce sur cet
élève aujourd'hui ce que vous dites
c'est un hilare il a loupé sa vie ou est
ce que pour certains ils passent points
et roux entre guillemets et ça ça serait
grave alors
pour la plupart des élèves enfin d'après
ce qu'on m'a dit d'après ce que
j'entends d'après ce que je pense aussi
franchement il a il a raté sa vie pour
un truc qui ne vaut pas la peine
franchement et du de faire du mal à
quelqu'un sans aucune raison il a raté
sa vie donc là je pense même lui il en
train de repenser à ce qu'il a fait
j'espère vous feront vraiment qui
regarde ce qu'il a fait parce que voilà
c'est passé mais sinon il ya d'autres
personnes qui cumulent qui le prennent
pour un héros aussi tout à fait j'ai vu
des personnes sur eux alors qu'ils le
prennent point il roule sur les réseaux
sociaux ils disaient oui bravo et enfin
et donc quand j'ai vu les commentaires
comme ça j'étais encore plus choqué que
y'a des gens ils le supportent je suis
après voilà ça peut influencer toute
personne à faire du mal à quelqu'un de
l'établissement alors aujourd'hui risque
quoi déjà il va falloir voir son état
médical pour le moment ces examens
médicaux dans quel état il était est ce
qu'il ya une une veuve ce qu'on appelle
ainsi fait désirante un passage à l'acte
inspiré par quelque chose voilà ça
déterminera son degré de responsabilité
après il faut voir l'état de
l'enseignant donc heureusement ses jours
ne sont pas en danger mais comprend pas
l'état de l'enseignant
très remontée tablant même sur l'étal
est à oletta on s'en fout ça nous est
qui et qui suivra ces aides se sont
formés chose si elle même sapée grave
d'accord mais c'est vrai qu'il faut
peut-être changé à vendre et faut voir
l'état l'état psychologique des garçons
voir pourquoi il a fait ça trouver le
motif s'il ya un motif et qui a une
préméditation il faut que ce soit
condamné mais dur parce qu'on touche pas
on touche pas à l'enseignement les
anciennes elles sont là pour nous
apprendre quelque chose qu'on voit la
saison touche pas aux enseignants et ça
c'est très grave et je suis même temps
il a 15 ans mais voilà mais à un moment
donné il faudra réussir un moment donné
parce que tu es mineurs jusqu'à 18 ans
ou dix sept ans les mecs j'en ai marre
d'entendre c'est un enfant à 21 ans il
était jeune ya 21 ans non les mecs
attendait faut changer des jeunes ils
vont vite maintenant c'est pas tant de
générations à nous on est onze et des
trucs et on avait pas internet envers
les jeunes vont vite maintenant il faut
peut-être changer un peu ça moi je pense
que déjà je suis content que cette
enseignante elle son envie d alors il
aura l'excuser or it et la moitié de la
peine d'un majeur ça moi je ne veux pas
changer en france je sais qu'il ya un
débat on n'est pas d'accord avec raymond
mais pour moi c'est les gars quand on
est d'accord avec vous c'est
vraiment avec mathieu canton il ya des
actes il ya des failles j tu veux pas
changer moi donc je veuille venger faut
vivre avec ça si je sais que des amendes
de 14 ans c'est pas un mec de 40 ans je
suis je suis je suis conscient de ça
mais moi ou même avec lesquels les gens
que je connais que 16 ans 17 ans tu te
rends compte le passage à l'acte pour
aller chez un prof avec un couteau mais
on est où là mais on est à un moment
donné il faut que ces jeunes il faut que
ces jeunes il va avoir c'est d'être une
s'il est reconnu coupable la moitié
paris je pense qu'il va être reconnu
coupable oui ça que tu te sens non mais
parce que c'est toujours agacé c'est
parce que j'ai pu me bourre juin
géraldine parce que encore une fois je
dormais rythme et symboles mais ce
symbole et il est tellement fort d'abord
on a poignardé une femme mais au-delà de
ça là c'est par ici maintenant on sent
pas aulas a une professeure l éducation
nationale et la tenterait nous expliquer
qu'il faut voir dans quel état il était
ce qu'il appelle bouffées délirantes
il revenait à huambo d'état son pardon
c'est l'amour figé assure c'est la loi
je sais bien j'ai le cul de cacher et
tout ça mais c'est ce que les séries
dans les bacs aujourd'hui moi on est en
train de se rendre tout va peut-être
faire bouger des choses puisque rien ne
marche mais selon on parle aujourd'hui
c'est hallucinant alors je vais parler
comme raymond comme un vieux con mais
quand nous on avait collé avec notre
moteur notre us notre us sur le truc
mais à aucun moment aucun amendement y
avait ces violences aucun moment on
pensait que ça se passait aucun
amendement il y avait une arme qui
rentrait à aucun moment ils viennent
agresser au don de soi ça n'existait pas
ça n'existait pas c'est extrêmement
grave ce qui se passe j'ai un côté de
moi gamin quelqu'un d'autre à nous
raconter que son pote à payerne et ça se
sa prof tu vois ce que je veux dire
gilles on marche sur les mains c'est
hallucinant et c'est très triste
nazan quand on entend
ce qui se dit et ce qui ce qui peut
concourir puisque si les s'il n'est pas
responsable de ses actes il n'ira jamais
en prison l'eau qui va les vallées où il
ira dans un
sim city 4 icm en être il doit être
traité n'ira pas en prison à 105 me
cyril lecomte le môme qui avait une est
pas responsable
le monde qui avait frappé pour frapper
cette vieille dame dont on a parlé la
semaine dernière et il ya rené qui est
venu ici à l'horizon son père un départ
on sera là avec nous demain bon est ce
que tu sais ce qu'ils risquent jusqu'à
trois ans et demi de prison ça veut dire
que ce môme qui a quasiment câble qui a
voulu frapper pour tuer une femme va
sortir de prison à 17 ans et demi ça va
on ne met pas les mineurs en prison en
france
gilles là haut débit du mineur comme
l'était la mère en maison les inner
c'est fait pour les éduquer tout le
monde vous le dira à un mineur en prison
c'est un drame voilà ça ne sert à rien
fait un droit qu'il faut les éduquer
leur permettent de s'en sortir mettre un
mineur en prison c'est lui bousillé sa
vie en étant mineure aujourd'hui
170 gilles c'est ça qui est bon que tu
vaux près de castries s'est dit le
philosophe hardware c'est la loi
par rapport à sa peine oui alors tout
d'avoir enfin j'espère que en tout cas
dans tous les cas donc tout ce qui va
avoir et ce par mois qu'il se rendra
compte de son oeuvre sara lee sortirait
qui vraiment qui regrette ce qu'il a
fait et qui ne surtout comment ce pas
parce que je prends d'après ce qu'on va
voir et tout y avoir un procès si si
tout va bien mais tant mentalement après
voilà j'espère que y'a sandra content de
son match sinon voilà pour le mettre en
prison que l'on fermé parce qu'on va pas
laisser quelqu'un comme ça j'ai faim
elle est en cours avec nous
tranquillement bien sûr on peut pas être
tranquille dans une classe en train de
reprendre un cours quand un élève on
sait que un cet élève a essayé de tuer
en propre parce que il a 15 ans il a pas
12 ans s'arrêter un petit genre pourrait
dire qu enfin y'a pas d'ici fin mai à
papa n'a pas su s'y met il est si c'est
pas vraiment ce qu'il fait mais là le
jeune il a 15 ans quand même ça veut
dire maintenant il a dû penser à son
acte et
agir au moment venu voilà des parents
cet enfant il a des parents qu'est ce
qui est sûrement mais il doit pas être
souvent leur programme
dernière chose
mathieu je joue je te vois tu n'étais
bassam bah oui question ben idir ayasse
zen
non mais au-delà de ça au-delà de ça
évidemment heureusement que cette femme
va s'en sortir 1 mais le fait qu'elle
s'en sorte c'est que finalement une fois
de plus bas dans une semaine on parlera
plus de ce sujet encore une fois un buzz
soutient que j'avais des pour rené
effectivement j'avais bien vu une
semaine après on est sur une femme qui
était la prof qui a été poignardé et la
semaine prochaine malheureusement il y
aura ici quelqu'un qui viendra nous
raconter une horreur et il a prolongé
vous dire j'ai d'ailleurs que jg je le
dis
en fait il faut tout revoir mais
vraiment tout revoir qui va et tout leur
dire mais malheureusement tu trouves que
tu représentes aujourd'hui laly vieille
institution ainsi les vieilles décision
et qu'aujourd'hui il faut que ça aille
plus vite on travaille plus fort et il
faut qu'ils aient des exemples forts et
aujourd'hui c'est dissuasif je te dis
c'est cesser avec des idéologies comme
étienne que la france en est où l aumône
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que ça n'avance
pas c'est si c'est un peuple et les pays
le plus violent voilà voilà plus les
gens d'europe en anglais je rappelle que
certains hommes politiques voulaient
qu'aujourd'hui et le droit de vote à 16
ans pour ces élections là je sais te
dire si aujourd'hui on considère qu'un
gamin de 15 ou 16 ans et restera pour
voter si les ressorts pour voter dit
qu'il aurait elle en prison mais
peut-être taire non mais ça ça va
peut-être faire